i love talking to this guy when he comes
on the show i love listening to him he
is just a terrific
football mind and a terrific broadcaster
part of the monday night football crew
on espn he will be calling the pro bowl
and he's part of espn super bowl
coverage from wait for it disneyland
so i guess they're going to rename mr
riddick's wild ride can't wait for that
lewis riddick back here on the rich
eisen show how you doing louis
i'm doing good my man how are you i'm
doing great so you're gonna ride that
monorail with uh with who who's on the
monorail who's getting that uh passport
to fun with you for the super bowl
um
when it comes to rides when it comes to
disneyland i don't know who's gonna be
on them but i'm not gonna be on anything
that goes any faster than a monorail i
can tell you that louis
my speed is fired my days of that my
speed is it's a small world after all
that is my speed
you and me both man you would be both
fact and i am not even driven crazy by
the fifth different version of the song
by room number five as your travel
throughout the world i love it
i love it i hear you so that's my wife's
favorite ride
your favorite one that'll be great uh
let's talk about the here's the here's
the transition wait for it here let's
talk about the wild ride that is gonna
be super uh bull uh matchups being made
from championship sunday here we go um
uh what do you make of the afc
championship game and how that's going
to play out best you can tell lewis yeah
look um
i think for everyone
and it just is it's just about everyone
who loves
offensive fireworks and star power
i mean this is the game for you clearly
because it seems like people are more
inclined to
to lean towards defense being optional
and i'm not saying that these teams
won't try it won't play good defense
because they will and they have some
good defensive coaches on both of these
teams but i think points will be
plentiful
i think obviously kansas city will move
the football they move the football
against everyone
they have multiple different ways of
moving the football and i think they
will be successful in doing that in this
in this game same goes for cincinnati
especially considering how
i think kansas city's back end you know
the third level their defensive
secondary has really been inconsistent
and has struggled some and we just if
tyron matthew at any point in time is
not able to
you know finish this football game for
whatever reason it really seems as
though they melt down in the back and so
i think points are going to be at a
premium
i think the team that tackles the best
in this game is really going to be the
one that winds up getting out of this
football game because in that first game
jamar chase has 266 yards receiving the
first time these teams played 155 plus
or 153 yards off it came after the cash
yeah that's just ridiculous
and you know tyree can do the same thing
on the flip side you know travis health
can do the same thing michael hardman is
just a step slower than tyrek than tyree
kill
so whoever can tackle and get these guys
on the ground will have the best chance
to win
but this may come down to a last last
possession ball game too which brings
into a brings into a whole another
discussion about overtime and i saw your
thoughts about it and i think mine have
have gained a lot of traction this week
too about how we think overtime should
be handled but i think this game could
come down to the same type of situation
that came down in the divisional round
between casey and buffalo well i'd like
to put a pin in that overtime talk for
just a moment i will remove it later on
after we get through these games uh i
was just looking here while you were
talking at the monday night football
schedule you did not have the bengals
that will obviously change for future
years uh what makes joe burrow so good
what makes him so damn good
it's blue's voice
confidence
not being someone who gets rattled
despite being so young simply because he
just he's just wired that way that's in
his dna he's always been a guy who has
looked at challenges
as this being temporary roadblocks and
not something that can slow him down
whether the you know how he handled his
college career you know being a transfer
from from ohio state and going down to
going down to lsu and then winning the
national championship for
his rookie year having his knee blown up
and then coming back faster than anybody
thought he would never blinking behind
an offensive line that can be like swiss
cheese in front of him he never throws
anybody under the bus he never seems to
complain his con
facial expression never changes his body
language never changes and everybody
else sees that rich
and they go well damn if he's not
complaining
and he's getting the tarp beat out of
him back here and he's still throwing
darts and throwing lasers out here well
then we need to step it up and find a
way to come through and that's not just
on offense but that's some defensive
special teams too and that's what makes
like you know you talk to enough enough
great athletes high performance players
that's what makes those guys great
is that other people feel like they need
to raise their level to match theirs and
not let them down and at a young age
that's what he's become for that
football team
and
look his his play on the field as far as
his movement in the pocket decision
making fluidity with which he delivers
the football accuracy
you know great situational awareness he
has all that stuff but it's the
intangible stuff man that is just
transferring and coming along with him
at every single step
that makes you go
that's what a number one overall pick at
quarterback is supposed to look like
well he wasn't yet killing it and he
wasn't on his butt though as much in you
know week 17 as he was
last week and i'm wondering if you think
that that
adjustment that the bengals might
attempt to make having seen what the
titans did with the with their line
uh and what the chiefs think they might
be able to make some hay with with jones
and
and clark etc and and how you think is
is that
that the the key to this game as well
or or just going to be a different set
of circumstances different teams rematch
just a few weeks later so on and so
forth what do you think well i think
it's part of it um i think if you just
looked at the number of times he was hit
and sacked in the tennessee game you
would assume if you hadn't watched the
game well there's no way they know
there's no way cincinnati wins that game
there
so
even if kansas city is able to get the
same kind of pressure look they had four
stacks in their first game against
against cincinnati
what the titans had nine yes so even
even if even if you put him down that
number of times it still doesn't
guarantee that you're going to win the
game but i will say that i think
they'll try to protect him better i
think that kansas city will
exert maximum you know commit as many
guys as they possibly can without
exposing their secondary to that wide
receiver corps as they can to try and
rattle joe
and i think they'll be
i think they have a good chance of being
even more successful at it because
you're playing at home
the crowd noise is going to help you
just like the crowd noise help tennessee
in tennessee and you know arrowhead the
loudest place in the nfl and these guys
will be juiced up even more
and they also know that look they got to
make up for some deficiencies on the
back end that are just they're just
glaring they just are what they are so
but frank clark
chris jones
melvin ingram those guys they have to be
on it man and and i think there's just
really not a whole lot
cincinnati can do about it right now
there's no scheme that you can really
draw up now that's just going to
magically cure their issues that's a
personnel issue it's not a scheme issue
lewis riddick here on the rich eisen
show monday night football espn's family
of football programs and who would be
uh calling the pro bowl coming up in las
vegas nevada right here on the rich
eisen show what about the nfc
championship game
you know six straight in a row shanahan
has beaten ran the uh mcvay rams now
here comes the one with the most stakes
on it um what
what do you think will be the best
chance to make sure the rams break this
losing streak louis
wow man you know this one really just
comes down to a to a mentality
really i mean look there's a lot of
things that are always gonna
they're always gonna play a factor as
you know turnover differential
situational football blah blah blah get
off the field on third down bruno
football blah blah blah we know all
those things that lead to
winning in the nfl but this is really
about a mentality
and i remember when we did the first
game
of theirs this year the first matches
that they had
in santa clara and sitting in the
production meetings and talking to kyle
shanahan and the first question i asked
them was i said look last year meaning
in 2020 when you guys played them in
santa clara i said the first thing that
jumped off the screen to me from this
and i always start with the tv copy and
then move to the all 22 tape copy when
i'm watching these games i said was the
sound of the hitting in that game
because there's no fans in the sand and
the mics are picking up everything and i
said it physically sound like you guys
were delivering them a rear end kicking
that was epic and he goes that's how we
want to play them
that's how we feel like we can beat them
because we feel as though he said quote
listen i told devo samuel this needs to
be a depot type of game
you need to be snatching chains stealing
bicycles just like the character in the
movie and that's how we're gonna that's
how we're gonna play them because they
don't wanna play that way you know what
they play them that way every time man
it goes up another level but they play
everybody that way but it goes up
another level when they play the ramp
and that's gonna be the deciding factor
in this game how is aaron donald how was
uh jalen ramsey how is bond miller how
are the you know cooper cub odell ben
how are they going to respond are they
going to match them blow for blow or at
some point in time in three three and a
half hours are they going to make a
mistake or wilt or not be able to
withstand that kind of intensity because
that's what san francisco counts on
they count on being tougher than you
and being you know good at what they do
but they count on being tougher than you
and i love that about them
i i'm
i'm not the get off the lawn old
crotchety guy but i am a guy who likes
that kind of football
because that's the era that i played in
an era that i love and that's how those
dudes play man and that's why i love
that matchup and i'm just wondering
like
they say you know people always say no
they're not in my head they're not in my
head you know what hey but we just we
had our chances i'm not my head i don't
have any lack of confidence bs when a
team beats you that many times and they
beat you a certain way and you know what
the reason is
that starts to play on your psyche and
you start questioning yourself
especially at those crunch times in the
game where it comes down to i know what
they're going to run i know they're
going to put 19 in the backfield and
they're going to let him run
can i get him down though
when he sits and he dips his shoulder on
me is he going to run my rear end over
am i going to miss this tackle
you know george kittle gonna put me on
my back
that's those are the questions they have
to answer and that's why
that game gives me goosebumps because
that's that's that's really what this
game is all about man yeah that's what
it's all about
i mean you you got my juices flowing
just hearing every last word you said i
mean that monday night game you're
referring to uh it was really the first
time all year the niners looked like the
niners of 2019. and that was the night
where odell made his debut robert woods
had just blown his knee out stafford
forced that ball to start the game
down the field they were not on the same
page clearly odell and him um but now
they do appear to be that way and
stafford made the plays i mean
if i told you that the uh rams would
make four huge mistakes turnovers
in and blowing a huge lead against the
rams you know your thought would be
staff would have to make one of them he
made none of them and as a matter of
fact he made the throws to cup to kind
of save the day so what about this team
now even though they they they did not
respond to that sort of niners mentality
in the third quarter um of that week 18
game where they may have had the best
chance to eliminate the niners of
anybody else
in this postseason i i do think they are
different
i do think that this football team
has found its groove its rhythm its
formula for winning
i think they know starting with that
game that monday night game that we did
that they can't just be a getting the
getting the shotgun and throw it 45-50
times and let matthew stafford just
dazzle us with his arm they know that
this has to be more like 2017 2018 rams
where it's sony michelle cam akers lots
of inside outside zone running the
football and then play action pass
getting the gun sporadically let matthew
dazzle you a little bit
but they know that they have to play the
tough guy game too because it helps
their offensive line it helps the whole
mentality of their football team
and i do think they know that that's
what it's going to take against this
team
i think they and i think defensively
look aaron donald knows that he has to
be three-time mvp at the defensive mvp
aaron donald von knows that this is why
we were why i was brought here jaylen
ramsey knows i need to play in the slot
against debo i need to be as close to
the action as possible don't park me out
here on the corner covering someone you
know cover it look as good as brandon
nyuk is don't park me out here where
they can just formation me out of the
game
leave me in the mix leave me in the
action here i think these guys know
that that's what it's going to take and
they have some damn good players in
order to get the job done so i don't
think i don't think they lack confidence
i'm just saying rich
that
whereas they know what the formula is
and what it's going to take
the question is
when it comes down to it when it's
fourth quarter and you're tired
and all of a sudden
19 starts lining up in the backfield
even more
and it's third and sixth and you're
going you know when most teams throw it
here but kyle's going uh-uh it's third
and seven i'm gonna run it
i'm going to dare you to stop it and i'm
going to put big trenton williams in
motion and i'm going to have him just
blow up your defensive end like he did
to rashaan gary what are you going to do
about it
that's what that's what i'm waiting to
see how the rams respond to that
lewis is picking i don't know i guess no
no no i mean so based on your your your
your analysis
would it be safe to say chiefs and
niners super bowl 56
or what what do you think from you yeah
yeah that's what i'm picking even though
like
i i'm never gonna bet against patrick
and the dna of that team in kansas city
although
you just love everything since he's
doing and joe burrows is stunned jamar
chase is ridiculous
and when it comes to the nfc though
look
i i can't say this enough i love
everything that is aaron donald
everything
where he grew up school he went to
naturally
what he has made himself into
three-time defensive i mean it's
sickening
how much respect i have for that young
man
jaylen ramsey is an absolute warrior
got to talk to him just a couple weeks i
mean these guys and sean mcvay matthew
stafford i mean i love these dudes it's
hard for me to pick this game it really
is
but i just believe
when i sat and talked to kyle we were in
there in those meetings
and he looked and he said
i'm glad you brought that game up from
2020. because then i'm going to tell you
what i told our team this week i told
debo this needs to be a devo type of
game that stuck with me all year long
and they came out and they play that way
man and i just i'm drawn to that not to
say that the rams can't play that way
right i'm drawn to that
that physicality aspect of the game that
has been legislated largely out of the
game they find a way to do it within the
rules and it's beautiful and so i'm
always going to bet on that
uh before i let you go i know we've
talked for a while here but i i told you
uh louis riddick i love talking to you
so uh i'll unpin it now your overtime
thoughts you said uh you think there
needs to be a change to the overtime
rules no you know what no i i don't but
the only thing i think okay when i've
heard this whole discussion but i i was
one of those people who believe that
look
we have become conditioned to believe
that the only good football there is
left in the world is football that is 55
54 38 35 45 41
defense i mean offense up and down the
field bombs away blah blah i don't
believe that
see we we make football we say football
the most is the greatest team sport in
the world until
all of a sudden
it actually looks like that and we
aren't getting the scoring then we go
this stinks we need more scoring we need
more scoring
i i don't like the argument of well it's
not fair that josh allen didn't get a
chance well yeah actually it is fair
because those are the rules they had 13
seconds to stop this offense with one of
the best defenses in the nfl and quite
honestly strategically they blew it
they blew it it's a three-phase game man
just like in green bay green bay special
teams against san francisco in the
divisional round blew it
they they just flat out blew it and you
know what that's what makes the game so
beautiful the only thing i would change
as far as the sudden death nature of
overtime is this if you want to
pre-determine who's going to get the
ball first so teams know what they're
dealing with as it comes down the
current time fine right but i like the
sudden death nature of it because it
puts all three phases on notice
if you're going to kick off you better
pin them deep defense you better be
ready to go and get off the field on
third down because if they drive the
ball down the field score it's over
it's over
so
man up and get it done i i like that
aspect of it i like that pressure
pressurized aspect of it i don't think
that everything that that is fair in the
nfl always has to involve well let the
quarterback have a chance to do it
no the hell with that
i don't like that
i'm with you um you and not every
overtime is going to have both defenses
gassed or come in a game where both
quarterbacks have played
the position maybe at the highest level
on the biggest stakes that we've seen i
mean my god josh allen is so the real
thing it's you know
i mean and you know the buffalo area
from your playing days too that's what i
said to bill's mafia right now it's dark
but there's a dawn my god is there a
dawn and a son and it's josh allen
that's my question
take care of yourself i hope
i don't have any plans to be in
disneyland um but uh i do hope to run
into you certainly super bowl week for
sure absolutely absolutely i hope so too
man thanks a lot for having me on any
time any time uh the great louis riddick
right here on the rich eisen show you
should follow him on twitter a great
follow on twitter hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here